wow
it's kind of nostalgic i'm getting a
little emotional
oh sorry
you guys just made me cry on camera
what's up gq this is lunar zx and this
is my style history
[Music]
oh my god how'd you guys find this
how did you find this you've been trying
to stop this oh my god
okay well this is from like one of my
first music videos for a song called
carry on that i think i have a pending
lawsuit for well i was wearing those big
felipe boots that everybody was wearing
that year some rep jeans and this really
nice yellow jacket you know do you still
have that jacket i actually do still
have that jacket i think it's somewhere
put up in my closet or something yeah
yeah that's iconic right there that's
actually the jacket on the cover of my
first ep ii it was one of the only
outfits i ever had at that time if you
could go back and like just send your
voice to you at this time what would you
say i probably wouldn't say anything
because i'd probably throw him off track
and he wouldn't be here
i just let us like you as like watch him
from a distance because if i tell him yo
you're going to make it then he'd be
comfortable you know
let's see the next one
this is me performing at the 2019 vma
awards
oh my god this outfit i actually almost
got burned alive
because this alpha's supposed to light
up you know you're supposed to see pink
lights but now you just see like this
white outfit and whatnot so right before
the performance my outfit started to
smoke you know oh [ __ ] and you know i
thought i was gonna have like a really
bad accident i was like this is gonna be
iconically terrible but luckily i didn't
catch on fire
i finished the performance would i wear
it again no
nah were you scared in that moment
i was definitely a little scared i was
like hoping like you know i would make a
performance without like dying or
anything
i wanted to have like this futuristic
looking outfit supposed to light up on
the chest i think the knees the arms
like a lot of this outfit is supposed to
light up even the shoes kind of like
tron yeah i guess it does give tron vibe
so i guess i succeeded hans you say tron
what does the 73 mean i forgot why i
chose that number 73 but you know
it's better than 69
69 it's like the sex number guys
you are the most casual person in this
photo i am huh
i never thought about that how often
does that happen it happens a lot i like
to be comfortable and that was a really
comfortable outfit especially if i'm
gonna be drunk as [ __ ] off my ass do you
remember this night or is it like a blur
i feel like this was probably vmas night
of 2019 possibly just a big t and some
black jeans nothing crazy looks like an
ed hardy t is it ed hardy i don't think
it's ed hardy at hardy-esque maybe and
hardy-esque the woman on the left and
the pink is hodo she's my stylist the
best styles of all time dj broadway you
can tell who he is because he outdressed
everyone in this picture and two guys
take a date ship those are my producers
they're really amazing and unbeatable
definitely one of the best outfits i've
ever worn ooh this is bt awards right
here this came out really nice this is
probably the heaviest outfit i've ever
worn
yeah you say you're like a comfort guy
and this doesn't look comfort to me that
was
not comfortable but it was definitely
worth it very much hard to walk in and i
almost failed like a million times but
at least i look good i was like wow
who's that hot guy falling i was like
it's me uh you wore two outfits this
night yeah
they were both really great and i was
like i have to get these both out there
you know i feel like it's the first time
i've ever
went to a red carpet and left and then
came back to the red carpet where are
you going and changing
i went to the bt awards bathroom and
changed like in like two minutes
and like had to do it really fast and
then run back out before the show
started and i had to go and get ready to
perform your chest looks great
really great chest is that wax or a
shave
i don't really wax shave my chest hair
just started growing in recently i
believe still got a few more years of
puberty ah that this is the fave
christopher john rogers he's amazing
look at his outfit this is like prince
inspired one of my first like outward
colorful flamboyant outfits i feel like
i wore in public and if you look at the
pictures of the audience you would spot
me immediately because there's literally
nobody else was like wearing these
vibrant ass colors oh like when the
camera pans you know exactly where yeah
they're like oh found one last yeah
people were like saying i look like a
batman villain yeah and i was like
thanks
like riddler or something no no no no
not really someone else i forgot who now
you look like a jojo character yeah they
said jojo character too right how'd that
make you feel i don't know i think
that's really sick because the
characters are all really nice
well-dressed you know really cool looks
oh my god this outfit was very much
traumatizing i was feeling really
comfortable
and then you know as i saw the pictures
of it i just
i felt really terrible
oh my god it's a meme now though so i
guess that's a good part what's the mean
just this is the meme like that's the
meme
i think i saw some people saying you
look like someone from sss tricky yeah
that was one of the most popular ones
too
but you know what it's pretty iconic
ten years from now you'll be like wow
yeah look what little nazak's did look
what he wore it was hard for me to id
like where the shirt was it was hard for
me to look at it too
maybe i'll wear that for halloween this
year i'll be a little nausea from the um
snowboarding game um this is met gala
this was a moment and this is my first
met
i feel like i really actually just went
out there and smashed it not to toot my
own horn beep beep this is one of the
greatest weekends of my life versace and
hodo did their thing those golden abs i
look like a superhero there's a couple
of inspirations people say like they
better not don't show me the cp3o thing
you showed me it i haven't watched star
wars yet why um
i haven't watched lord of the rings yet
either or the godfather a lot of those
popular movies do you watch steven
universe i think you look a little bit
like yellow diamond yellow you know what
i was actually going to commission
somebody to like take these outfits and
like position them as the diamonds you
know the road would be like blue diamond
and maybe i don't know who
who i would be in this like tattoo maybe
that's white diamond or yeah who's going
to be the other diamonds yeah who's
going to be pink diamond though yo [ __ ]
pink diamond ah we love pink diamond you
know she did what she had to do i
actually love that you've never seen
star wars but you love steven universe
yeah i feel like star wars is decent but
steven universe is next level wow i love
this outfit this is a fun night i feel
like i met someone this night and then
had a relationship with him
did not end well uh this outfit though
right and you know you got this little
kind of see-through what's the word
it's like mesh mesh mesh shirt yeah uh
yeah i felt like tom cruise is that real
snake skin no
we love animals
oh this is via maze and the grammys one
of my favorite ones
and one of the more
known ones the pink versace yeah versace
versace it's actually
i guess it's the harness that really
gave it to to the people you know it's
like a bdsm cowboy yeah it was like they
were like okay the harness we're feeling
it now yeah it was the most probably
probably the most gay cowboy look of all
time i think what's so cool about this
is you're taking like a look that's like
so queen essentially americana and then
like [ __ ] it up like making it
completely different
did you get like backlash from that
no no but you know what i do see a lot
of they'll be like rappers in my dating
that have tupac maybe like rappers now
and it would be a picture of me in the
cowboy pink outfit it's like what
listen when did you care about tupac's
fashion sense
um
this is a fun one
it looks really hot sexy spicy that's
versace i'm getting like a little bit of
prince but a lot of rick james i got a
lot of those comments
but what you weren't thinking that going
in
not at all i want to try different kinds
of wigs though i feel like i've done
this one before yeah maybe i'm going to
have like some kind of cool mohawk i'm
going to bring mohawks back oh [ __ ] like
a tall one is there like a travis pickle
style like actually
maybe i shaved my head ball and tattoo
mohawk there that took me
this is fun this is a really fun time in
my life
looking back on it i was too in my head
but this is a fun time this outfit was
hot as [ __ ] and i was literally going
around
passing out gift cards to people it was
like hey check out my new song holiday
check out my new song in this hot
burning outfit i'm gonna get out here
and do what i need to do to get these
numbers baby and it worked
it definitely worked why did you make a
holiday song well i make a holiday no
it's funny i actually made the song like
eight months in advance and it was
already called holly and i was like you
know what let's put this together and
let's say okay this is doing the
christmas theme i had a lot of fun i
feel like that whole era it was almost
like oh [ __ ] like lunasex is like family
friendly now and then you drop like call
me by your name
were you pulling a bait and switch on us
or what's the deal it was supposed to be
coming by your name first but then um we
had some things happen
and holiday isn't family friendly like
i'm nearly in the song saying i got hoes
on hoes like it's like i don't know what
family friendly came from i guess the
santa claus is associated with
family and love but you know not this
one that's saint nazak's literally
talking about bottoming in the song like
well let's continue yep ooh the big t
awards again
okay this is iconic this is legendary
this is necessary i felt like i had to
[ __ ] before this performance
was so nerve-wracking going out there in
front of all those people especially
like other rappers and whatnot in my
little skirt and twerking and
singing kong by your name very fun
performance though i would wear this
again maybe to like some kind of party
or something in hollywood and just like
randomly show up like this right yeah
this is a 100 out of 10.
oh my god
i think this is one of my first flights
ever
i wore the hell out of that nike shirt i
thought that was the best shirt of all
time
i feel like this is when i first got to
los angeles and like everything was
starting to happen you know old time
road has just taken off i recorded
panini in this shirt i went to the
lakers game in this shirt i met the
people at the label i went to the tick
tock uh headquarters i even went to
apple to the beats one radio thing this
is all in one day by the way i did so
much [ __ ] in one day in this shirt you
still have it ah i don't know i think i
got rid of it but you got the picture
yeah i got a lot of pictures of this
shirt so you're the kind of guy that
takes selfies in an airplane bathroom
then at that time i mean because it's
like how many times you get on an
airplane at that time you know it was
like probably my second flight ever i
was like holy [ __ ]
sup guys post the instagram
oh this this is from the best music
video of all time call me by your name
the denim everything
even the nails that's fire marginal is
not a reference i just saw other people
saying it so i was like oh that's funny
yeah why do you have the actual like
scan of this
like how did you possibly get that
this is like my performance at the
grammys there was big knives and little
knots and we made not squared it was
pretty cool did you know this
performance that entire back was opening
the whole time and i couldn't turn
around no
yeah i couldn't turn around and what's
the inspiration here like a punk rock
slash blade slash i get some matrix in
there yeah matrix two i was trying to
get together i was gonna get around to
it
wow
it's kind of nostalgic i'm getting a
little emotional
um
this one this is at the tom ford event
which i was invited to this is actually
a women's suit that i made fit me
this is really fun
i had a great night there
miley was there i think sierra was there
this is just a good time the outfit i
would wear it again
actually i probably wouldn't because i
think the button popped at the end of
the night could not take lona's eggs
what is it about it that makes it makes
you emotional
uh about what about the outfit or
looking no it's just like going through
all these i'm like wow it's been a
journey yeah yeah all right final one
coming up
oh my god
this is funny because it looks because
it looks like a banana is in my hand but
it's really like the phone i've never
seen a phone in a hotel bathroom
except at this hotel this is probably
the first hotel that i went to
oh my god
this these squirming trunks i forgot
where i got these from was it h m
i don't know but i thought these were
fire
uh this is probably one of the best days
of my life
what happened that day
i think this is still the same day as
like the um the nike the nike the nike
shirt i was posting so much i would post
like 30 times a day because everything
is just so new
um
oh
um yeah
it's like a different person you're
looking at here
that's like a different person oh i'm
sorry
don't cry baby
um yeah
that's me yeah
yeah i would wear i still have these
swimming trunks i still have these
screaming trunks
what was your favorite outfit of all
my favorite one
um
that nike shirt
and mikey sure did something man now
i've already met gala
i'm gonna remember that meg gala that
was super fun you guys just made me cry
on camera i'm sorry
it's sweet though it's beautiful
god you're gonna make me cry all right
we gotta cut let's cut we're done